okay next I am very pleased to introduce
our speaker uh Joshua Herman uh Joshua
Herman is an amateur data engineer who
has been self- teing various techniques
with a particular focus on Transformer
architectures in relation to how they
can be used in natural language
processing NLP for his day job he is a
compliance engineer at Bank of America
previously Joshua worked as a software
engineer and web developer he has 10
years of experience in software
development and Engineering he graduated
from UIC with a bachelor's of Science in
um the engineering College um and then
also want to give a shout out for our
host tus here's
Michelangelo hey everybody I'm
Michelangelo um welcome to tus we are um
a we build a financial research platform
for uh Financial investors so in
particular a ton of text data think like
SEC filings and earnings and events call
transcripts and things like that that
help uh Financial investors research
companies they might want to invest in
uh we use a ton of python on the
engineering side but also uh I run
machine learning and so we do a lot in
the pi data ecosystem uh and also llms
so super excited for the talk and
welcome if you need anything I'll be
here
so so uh this is uh going to be
interesting talk um this this uh project
has been talked about at three places um
basically I redid one it the original
one was
uh in Vegas for uh Devcon
31 was
a a demo lab where it would be like a 20
minute demo it keep on repeating itself
over a twoh hour period
the strange things about it was that I
was able to actually
introduce myself to new features that I
didn't know about unfortunately the
system is down because of um doing some
upgrades by adding a few video cards to
my home
lab I have a home lab um as the hosting
because a Amazon charged me $700 once
because I didn't show something off so
um I do myself hosting although I should
also probably have a backup system in
AWS so what it means by a natural
language Network scanner is that you put
natural language inputs and then um a l
large language model interpret it and
use specified
tools or attempt to answer the
question it's really an agent based
system called a zero shot react
system you can see similar things in gp4
when you when you add tools like wolf
room so a little bit more expansive of
who am I already been in introduced to I
also would like to um thank the pi data
host because I forgot my laptop which
had me sort of redo this presentation by
going to the Apple Store on my
phone you can find the code for this
software here it's called SECU day I
actually you may find it on the Defcon
website called Saturday and I and since
there's too many name collisions I
renamed it to SECU day because that's
not found it's and I was able to
register that
[Music]
domain um uh can be found at at Zer gang
on Twitter Discord and Reddit
um don't ask why I chose
that and it's open source I
have it's on GitHub as I stated before
this is what it looks like it's in the
paty2 license few people have
started it's the project is really a
more of a prototypal stage you'll have
to very complex to set up and I haven't
set up like a doer image or you know I
have okay directions but it's very
involved setup due to its architecture
that'll will go
later but I think it would be more
interesting now to show off like what it
does
and so like example
usage with all these L models also SEC
day is also intended to have an S not
only a web web interface which a lot of
people
are thinking of but also a SMS
interfaces can also be able to be used
basically
anonymously as long as you could get a
cell
phone so this is a negative or this is a
use of it through SMS like what is the
ipv address of devon. Peg does not host
a does not resolve to an ip4 address
mainly because Peg is a TLD that doesn't
resolve and two if that TLD did resolve
um the host name defc con. Peg would
have to be registered so really this is
a complex set of actions it reads the
input reasons about it and writes the
output and this is an inference
mode um conversational and zero shot
action meaning it's looking at the tool
descriptions and this
is using the bash tool which they've
renamed shell tool in Lang
chain and then trying and then it
probably
usually either uses curl trace route
or um to do that
or and then this is another thing where
it's interpreting the input and the
output and using
tools I've seen it use either ping or
trace route or dig it I'm not due to the
state of the upper llm I there are
unpredictabilities on how it inputs and
outputs data and also and
also open AI changes the
llm almost constantly now like they have
much higher context
Windows there's a lot of rumors and they
don't really publicize how even
GPT the gpt3 that they have the gpt3 in
uh their archive paper is 175 billion
parameter model but now they have this
thing called gpt3 turbo and that's not
publicized at all either is like gp4
turbo like we only have rumors about
what gp4 uses
or is it's like it could be
um like around maybe 300 billion or
three figures billion parameter models
that are all reading the input that's
one rumor but there's nothing
definitive this is more reasoning so
this
uses well you'd think it uses it either
uses ANM map or it can use showan for
this it actually uses showan but it also
explains to you what it does so after
the port scan it then reasons about what
does that information mean because
usually in a port scan the like the NMM
output would be 53 DNS but here it's
saying Port 80 is used for HTTP which is
the foundation of data say on the web so
it's reasoning not so you can see the
levels of reasoning on what's being
done you find that um giving more
information about how to use the system
makes it more instructive but because
it's sort of like clicking the button of
like do something random on google.com
or it the llm
interface isn't
really um in um it's not really
intuitive how to use it number one and
number
two I start to record what I've actually
successfully used it for when it does
something unintended like do I've seen
it do actually language translations of
this like I can write the above in
German and it'll output back into
German and everything else or Spanish it
doesn't work for um pictograph languages
like Chinese I think
not but
yeah then this is cloud flare just doing
IPv6 very similar what we've seen but
this time it
actually did spell check so cloud.com
did spell check and did what I meant and
do cloudfare decom which
is more emergent
Behavior I would say the most
interesting thing about the system is
that emergent Behavior does EX
exist with us with a limited set of
tools and zero shot react um
[Music]
agents um this is sort of when showan
doesn't tell you this I think if you pay
for a higher tier of showan it may tell
you this but I don't think so or
shouldn't I think Shan doesn't allow you
do this or it does but you have to if it
does I think you have to pay a lot or
and if you use an map that's not very
friendly and then here's like it's using
Trace path this is a little bit hard to
read but it's basically trace pathing my
machine
so this is more instructive and I did
Center stuff out um this this is like
more like when you host these
applications you also see you also have
to do a good security
model you have to consider
if the output into an agent will reveal
information about that
person also I don't use Comcast
anymore so it's not that bad but these
llms since they have behavior that is
undefined or can't be
totally um boxed because this is a
higher level
of security flaws that are not really
understood that well because we haven't
seen llms for a long
[Music]
time then it can do some basic stuff
this usually um python it'll it probably
wrote a python script for
this this is the creation of a bash
arbitrary bash scripts you can also have
it execute the bash scripts
too
then this is a thing I added recently
it's a so this is a malware detector
system
so there's this to there's this website
card virus total that has an API where
it can scan the
URL and then tell you how well it's um
if it's malware and the URL I have is
the malware test file uh if you want you
can download the malw test file and then
your Windows 10 installation may or may
not trigger it I'm don't use
Windows but yeah it should show up as
malware by some
scanner also added this is another to
added since Devcon which
is telephone lookup ability so it's um
tells you where it is when it
is how risky the fraud and so forth how
it was registers as a Vie
number this is
the I did have a
video of the website um so I do
have it's a little bit
small
you can
see it trying to it it says like the IP
address one11 where its location is
and then what parts are open in on 1.1.1
in German and then it'll put the output
in German used a tool
called I used a web tool for this that
I'll expand upon
it
um it's in the architecture
part and it'll do like so it's it has a
basic interface that the SMS tool is
it's one result it's not chaining
results it's like a um Google Star
interface as you can see it's uh does
have a on the top uses a yeah so this is
basically wrapping the system in
streamlit and it's and streamlets is a
declarative way to make a simple website
for your machine learning models it just
it's all in Python and then it just
generates the
interface so now now that we've shown
you what the magic it does that's we can
go more into what's happening
so we can start with the
implementation so this is the
output what you'll see
in the system when it's when
it's doing the inference system with
gp4 and after it's um it it pops off of
a rapid
mq
then it just tries to interfere then it
resolves it well resolves the chain and
then outputs the
thought so
[Music]
here an an incoming SMS comes in in from
twio to
flask flask can flask has flask and twio
can communicate with each other using
http I use NG grock to just give me a
addressable IP
address and then flask just basically
uses an HTTP style of interaction using
with
twillo and and so it sends and receives
the so it first you have an incoming SMS
it's interpreted by flas and then I do a
push onto Rabbid mq what was happening
was was I had a problem with
twio not being able to
resolve the output
because it was just taking too long and
tulo was timing out so I Ed rabbit
mq and use twio twice the first time I
used twio I I would receive a message
and the second time after the Lang chain
is out Lang chain is done I send an the
SMS back then this is by bypassed by
streamlet to do through like a push
query to Lang chain and then open AI
works with the tools then relays back
so can go from flask to the push query
under rabbit mq rabbit mq then if the
que is queue is not empty pops up the
first
Quay it it looks at all the workers the
workers will start the inference into
Lang chain and then Lang chain and open
B go back and forth
so Lang chain will take the input it
will it will then use descriptions of
these tools wol Alpha showan bash python
reverse total verse phone virus total IP
quality score and
census so how a zero shot reaction
system works is you have descriptions of
tools so then
gp4 or whatever llm you use will take
those descriptions of tools and attempt
to apply them and see if it gets a
satisfactory answer and once it
does open AI will return back to you the
final product and then relays back to
you either streamlet the streamlit way
it just
pauses until it's gotten back from Lang
chain
because of the way that streamlit is
designed it doesn't need this rabit mq
the whole rabit mq part of this is only
for the uh the problems that I had with
uh htbp Quest taking too long in
flask but streamlet doesn't need that so
I so for example for bash I say I bash I
say is already known because it's there
is a shell tool predefined you can
Define find your own tool really quickly
such
as virus total I say I just say it's a
very simple it's just a method and you
have to do two things you have the
method call which is which I is very
simple H it's like a requests it uses
requests
and the description so the tools are
just one method and one description and
then it can reason about the inputs and
then it does
that this is so this is Bash
reasoning that it needs to use ping
because I needs to Ping
google.com and then it computes The
Final Answer final when it has final
answer that that's the stuff that is
sent back to
you as you can see at the top it says I
need to use a shell
command to Ping google.com meaning the
first query was most
likely what is the latency that be
anything from latency google.com or
directly asking it to do ping
google.com but you but what this is if
it says I need to use a shell command
that's most likely reasoning that it
needs to use thing which is predefined
in they used to call it the bash tool
but now they call it the shell tool
which is accurate but it's also the
shell tool and the python tool are the
most are two of the
most um tools that have the biggest
impact in house how they can mess up
your system like just do AR RF
slash don't recommend that
dockerizing the system would help but
then it could still wipe itself so it
could
be there are ways you could mitigate it
like just running the Bas script into
some kind of like actual like it would
just execute itself in a VM so if it
deleted itself you could just spin up a
new
one so let's go into the
theory
this was sort of lacking in my
previous presentations I wanted to add
this
so we've we've been the from trans to
Transformers it's it's been a long time
uh bag of words
basically words bagage words well we
changing how we interpret the
vectors in two
Transformers the creation of attention
why we need um rnns or even
lstms which why though well by direction
or L
stms they all had limitations that we
had to push past to get the Transformers
Transformers needed an attention
mechanism but they also we figured out
that it didn't necessarily need the feed
forward parts the bidirectional lstms
and lstm models tried to aggress the
fact that we that language based inputs
are left to right they're not
squares and
rnns were more basic in
that
they they didn't have enough had memory
problems and then Warden benan bag of
words the left um
the left picture is probably the most
famous picture when we do Transformers I
would
say nearly everybody who's looked at
Transformers picture uses it even the
UST I would recommend um reading through
the Illustrated Transformer if you want
to know more about this then there's
like an lstn here on the right and on
the bottom is a basic the basic
classification tab X of a n
[Music]
network so this is a vastly simplified
uh training of a artificial n network on
the left we have
inputs on the right we have
classes and in the middle is the
training of the system or is the is the
uh null Network so as inputs we have a
like
you have a a
water a shell and a
starfish and
then the reasoning of what everything is
is being trained in the middle and then
the output is the classifications or the
things that want to classify the
starfish and this the C and this anulus
or
Circle so on the right are the so we
have the data we have the model in the
middle then we have the
classes class that's another thing
that deep Learning Systems can do while
there's a lot of talk about
generalize or generative AI that's
important uh classification is very
important too and it's not nearly as
stressed in Transformers in
general such as you can use it like to
classify programs or to classify if a
program has a security flaw like like
for example memory memory
Le like a cross type scripting leak and
so forth DARPA head Dara has at Defcon
31 Dara has
a llm based supply
chain competition that's going to
be in uh 202 um yeah 2025 it's a
threeyear
uh system where they're
doing an AI based competition they
Capture the Flag to
solve them they have they want to have
20 like 25 languages and where that you
have to reason on if a system has like
supply chain attacks
um
for security issues and
also the stranger part is that half of
them though will be CN
C++ security issues
but it will
be not as emphasized so half will be
like 20 model 20 languages like rust and
so forth like like obscure a little bit
more obscure languages
it may be less more scripting like
python but CN c++'s obviously heavily
emphasized due to the
UN the hardness of creating memory Safe
Systems and other attacks and the
prevalance of c and plus C and c++'s
languages in
general and here here is the execution
of that previous classifier where it's
classifying it into the
um based on the we see the starfishes
are classifi some of the surfaces are
classified one or the other and the
thoughts and so
forth this is more of a left to right
lstm where this doesn't have attension
well well this is where they started
doing ATT tension but it used sequences
in an RNN to do like a projection to do
Machine level translation that was the
first time this was done was actually
believe the upgrade to Google translate
where I could use rnns with seek to seek
models and finally Transformers have
like an input and output embeddings but
those are like just translating them
into
numbers tokenize numbers and then it
does two things it has multi-headed
attention in the input and the output
with feed forward n networks in the end
so it'll do the multi-headed detention
addition and normalization which is
normalizing you it
um and so forth
[Music]
so question
so the question is if you want to host
your own llm model is it
expensive by host what do you mean by
host you mean host it on your own
Hardware or or the cloud
or that's that depends on how many
parameters you
want so for me if I want to host uh like
code Llama Or derivative of that with 34
billion parameters you can do that with
a thread Ripper
with you can do that with a
Macbook you can do that with a thread
Ripper with 128 gigabytes of RAM
but it's you the main thing that
self-hosting it is memory size it's so
the better question
is how many
parameters do I you want and how and
the there's this thing called
quantization which is how much what will
I
tolerate because with quantization or
picking smaller parameter models such as
llama 7B well llama 2 like
7B you can host that on I would say that
most people's laptops could host that
here if you start hitting like the 34
billion parameter models that's
around believe uh 80
gigabytes um but these the small the
smaller parameter models will have
issues mainly in the
accuracy because you're so quantization
is is so there's 8bit there's fp16 and
fp32 so fp32 is most likely like what
was the model the original model and
then you need the parameter size so it
really depends on which ones you can
tolerate
so
gpd2 most um I would say everybody could
host it that can be hosted on a phone
too uh I believe llama one and two the
smaller parameter models can be hosted
on a phone but yeah as you create um but
you also quantize them meaning you
decrease the you
so let's go back here this is this will
be a good slide to actually do it um so
the actual weights in the middle they
can be floating points or not floating
points or bits so we're like truncating
it or like decreasing we're decreasing
the amount of bits like fp32 is a
floating Point 32 bit number but a four
or eight bit
number that that can that can half or
all the parameters so it makes it less
it can make it sort of less
accurate and make it easy to host it on
a less memory so it's sort of like wait
so yeah you it
[Music]
depends yeah like yeah at full
accuracy without quantization or without
if you want full accuracy without
quantization yeah you have need 40
gigabytes of vram
if you in but that's also constraint in
time um with
quantization you might be able to you
might be able to get it posted on your
computer but it will take a longer
amount of time to do the
inference so you just have to wait
longer but yeah certain models can only
be done in VM you have to convert them
you we'll still have to download the
weights it'll still be like a 40
gigabyte download or
something then you do there's these
tools um so llama CPP has some tooling
or you can there's a lot of tool um and
others have some tooling where you can
Quan quantize them to make them usable
for you um but you're going you're
giving up something you're giving up
speed or accurac most likely speed and
or
[Music]
accuracy
some of
them so Lang
chain wolf from
Alphas Das python were already part were
coded by Lang chain or shelters were
coded into Lang chain but
from Apple still needs an API key I
coded showan reverse phone virus total
IP quality score and
synesis it's just very easy simple once
you see the API definition or even like
the Json definition it's just a request
in the in the tool name and a
description it's like
k
yeah
that
after so like he here is show d
[Music]
man
oh
all
so there's two
[Music]
things this is just using the virus too
client
which is the their python um library and
then I pass it passes a
URL then you I return
[Music]
text then here's the description I
described that's really it
um yeah
anyone else have
questions the answer was how could I do
the output in Json
um I'm not totally sure how that that
could be done in Lang chain
but you might be able to do that either
with a
prompt
[Music]
um would say either hey
you yeah Lang chain usually has like
output alarms but maybe you could take
the text and reinterpret
it or do something else
with the tools I've never done that but
there's probably
some hack or even just there prob
there's a probably an API to do that
uh you'll probably have to mess with
like the agent that yeah if you probably
yeah I think if you traded a a custom
agent you could probably achieve that or
look into the langin API I've never done
that
[Music]
this is uh not Bank associate with where
I work at all this is a this is was
hobby just want to clarify that Bank of
America I'm not a this is not
representative of a Bank of America at
all but this is just
that's just what I do as a day
job well the first part I did mention I
don't know totally leads limitations are
but on the other hand I mean if you
asked it to like can synthesize programs
you can B scripts but you can't do like
Mo uh
you can't do certain things I uh
like maybe after a put scans like and I
don't think it's not designed to do
multi-step yet I've thought of doing
that um right yeah right now you can't
do
multistage or even you can't do like if
you've used chat. openai there's no
notebook system you can't reason about
its previous state it's just um so going
back to what I said about zero shot
agent what that means is a zero shot or
like a YOLO or one shot um meaning one
request reasons about it and that's it
it doesn't have any state in between you
can introduce memory I haven't done that
or I've what I really should introduce
though is uh is uh caching
because
the requests can become expensive the
way this got a lot more popular but
caching would be something but yeah so
it can can't do multi- level reasoning
it's I'm using the wrong
agent although and that's like currently
experimental I would say for
Transformers
even and even open Ai and there's rumor
uh nearly all teams are trying to figure
out the next step the step after
Transformers would be like systems that
do General reasoning and that scale line
nearly the the rise of Transformers is
really big because as as we've been able
to create these higher and parameter
models or even better trained ones using
they scale linearly with like the data
sets we have like it's weird that maybe
20 years ago we thought that
like High um truly intelligent well not
intelligent that machines that would
reason about this would either have a
semantic end uh meaning using like
ontologies or would be like created by a
brain scan or some other thing but I
think Kur had that prediction too but
instead it's sort of like
how how does an airplane fly it's an a
play doesn't fly by flapping its
wings um same with llms llms don't talk
by flapping their wings they ingest a
bunch of data scrape them Reddit which
when you think about it really is a like
the subreddit M male fashion device has
a lot of questions and answers the other
interesting thing is all of them are
rated by humans with
high very high and accurate human
output like that was one of the reasons
why I think that's one of the reasons
why Reddit was rumored to increase their
API prices because if like one time
Reddit goes down and Google goes like
Google search goes go bad the other time
is opening ey is actively scraping that
site getting these all these nice
question answers that have been done by
humans for
free so like these really high quality
results we just need terabytes of social
networks bunch of bunch of people that
played video games until we figured out
that they could be used by by general
purpose gpus which was 10 years ago
doing classifications of of
pictures which have why one of the big
reasons why um picture classification um
was done 10 years ago really quickly by
G general purpose gpus are they have a
notion of closeness of the pictures like
a picture and a te piece of text piece
of text needs needs attention because
this order of letter order of tokens in
the sequence don't necessarily are one
to one but pictures sort of have a
notion of closeness that's easy to
compute because it's a bunch of 3D tense
it's a bun it's a 3D um it's a
three it's a 2d object go two Matrix
with a with all elements as like three
well RGB so oh yeah the all color frers
but since you have that closeness it's
not I believe that's why the the 2D
classification worked very well but we
had to get attention to get a these high
for language to understand because
languages makes a huge tense a huge very
long tense tensor or M or
long tensor and Transformers allowed us
to have a sense of
closeness any other
[Music]
questions nothing
the this the question is is there
anything stopping people from doing
nefarious things such as looking atsh
Keys the answer is nothing um before I
said like yeah bash The Bash tool and
the python toour are very dangerous and
yeah but didn't didn't I didn't care
that I don't care that much you could
wipe my machine but I have back I do
have
backups that's they actually tell you
that well it's sort of obvious but they
do tell you in the documentation that
these are the most dangerous
tools like the best thing you would do
is make a either make a user that has no
permissions but can execute certain
tools but then they can't do root things
so but
yeah
you say that
again
[Music]
um it
can
be thing is is though I think I well
right now the system is off because I
had doing some upgrades putting gpus in
do some local training um but regardless
the question is like if I put a
paragraph in can it resonate the answer
is how long the paragraph is in because
the gp4 API has a context window I
believe it's 12,000 tokens or something
while it might take a long time it might
also time out might not
understand so yeah
[Music]
um because when you're submitting this
what happens is in the back end it does
the tool description
of the
prompt the tool description and then
reasoning and if you exceed the context
limit basically Lang chain will throw an
exception saying uh well API AP um
gp4 said uh context window gb4 said the
context window was too high so yeah
that's yeah that is that's a good
question that there are context Windows
to these apis
and or design and if you try to exceed
them you they'll just do they'll just
send you a failed request
[Music]
error can you say that
again well as I said before I don't it's
not memorizing it's a zero shot so it
doesn't have
memory so this has so Transformers have
no memory unless you tell them to have
for them or not you can you can do the
so and L chain does have abilities to do
that such as like vector like vector
stores
and so forth but or give it memory like
simple memory but yeah it depend it's
mind system is zero shot and zero shot
doesn't have independent memory between
queries
yeah also you can't break down a
multi-paragraph query like you said if
you were using it
um it would be better if
you to actually process that paragraph
either you'd use like you'd probably
have to do maybe tree of thoughts where
or well no it wouldn't it depends
on depends on what the paragraph would
say and how to do it um
like if your paragraph Was a set of
instructions or independent things to do
it could break it apart but you'd have
to add like a shell on either a tool on
top of that to tr or something else it
really depends on what the paragraph
would be
about you other
questions thanks uh the thank uh P at
Chicago for hosting me and uh thanks
every you
want